[Musica]
[Applauso]
siamo tre laureati in giurisprudenza e
attualmente svolgiamo un periodo di
tirocinio presso un pubblico ministero
in sostanza speriamo a diventare i
magistrati iniziamo questa sera
nonostante ci troviamo ancora una fase
incerta dove si direbbe ci troviamo tra
il già e il non ancora da un lato un già
conquistato certe volte a fatica e un
non ancora cioè ancora tutto in di
ventun divenire è bene che contributo
possiamo apportare qui stasera dove si
tratta di idee che tra di loro si
toccano
si accendono e diventano come scintilla
è stata questa qui la domanda che ci
siamo posti in ufficio mentre
ragionavamo effettivamente su quello che
poteva essere la portata del nostro
contributo e la risposta non è stata
facile da un lato pensavamo non abbiamo
un brevetto dall'altro siamo consapevoli
di non avere una biografia importante
descritta in poche parole
dapprima e dall'altro siamo anche
consapevoli non essere dei manager di
occuparci società che si si rapportano
con l'innovazione con fonti energetiche
alternative che sarebbe sostanzialmente
il tema che immediatamente richiama
l'idea di scintilla e tuttavia
dall'altro abbiamo la consapevolezza di
poter trattare di una storia una storia
che nasce dalle idee ma delle idee che
nascono la stessa storia si tratta di
una storia accaduta ormai sessant'anni
fa
più esattamente di un omicidio avvenuto
in sicilia una storia di vite spezzate
dove vedremo un testimone un
giovanissimo testimone un bambino
costretto a fuggire via e dall'altro un
pubblico ministero che si attiverà
soltanto tanti anni dopo in ordine a una
terribile a quella terribile vicenda
quel terribile omicidio
ebbene la considerazione fondamentale
tuttavia che occorre fare in questa sede
e che l'ufficio del pubblico ministero a
cui mi dovrò introdurre nella qualità di
narratore non è una realtà semplice anzi
è un crocevia di sofferenze di
difficoltà
di vicissitudini umane che tra di loro
si incontrano certe volte si scontrano
ma allo stesso tempo va vissuto con la
consapevolezza che la scintilla può
cambiare il modo di vedere le cose
ecco in questa in quest'ottica lascio la
parola al pubblico ministero la
scintilla del mestiere del giudice e
così come di qualsiasi altro mestiere e
il desiderio gaber diceva che il
desiderio è ciò che rende vivi tutto ciò
che si fa il nostro vero stimolo
interiore la scintilla non è il genio
non è nemmeno un talento sopraffino la
scintilla e la curiosità che alberga in
ognuno di noi che ciascuno di noi può
coltivare ma così anche come declinare
diversamente la scintilla è quella che
ti trafigge quando per la prima volta
incontro lo sguardo dell'ignoto marinaio
di antonello da messina quel sorriso il
sorriso di quel marinaio capisci che il
sorriso del marinaio che in ognuno di
noi ed enigmatico allusivo consapevole
ma soprattutto ironico
danni degli uffici che ogni giudice
abita si alternano mendicanti figli e
superate da padri autori di lupare
bianche ladre estorsore ma soprattutto
di persone che si difendono dal dolore
della conoscenza o meglio anche dal
pericolo della pietà e allora la
speranza ci dice che si può che si può
fare che si può suonare uno spartito in
maniera diversa
la scintilla è annidato comunque ovunque
si può accendere ma tutto cambia
era un po quanto è avvenuto
una sera i tanti anni fa era a milano
nel 2012 durante uno dei tanti
interrogatori ad alfonso che è un
collaboratore di giustizia di prima di
livello ecco quando ormai le domande
erano terminate e microfoni erano spenti
si accese una scintilla e ha colorato di
ironia tutto intorno così che anche le
mie domande si sono colorate ed ironia
ebbene gli chiesi ma è vero che lei è
stato l'unico combinato da lui in
persona
e vero che le è stato l'unico affiliato
di cosa nostra ad avere un furto in
persona come padrino questa domanda in
lui acceso la scintilla che divampò un
incendio di parole ed immagini
subito mi rispose mi disse sì per la mia
storia
ebbene quale era la sua storia disse
alfonso che lui era un ragazzo giovane
che come tanti era emigrato dalla
sicilia negli anni 80 con i genitori e
si dedicava furti rapine sequestri
spaccio e un giorno venne avvicinato da
due picciotti di mazara del vallo che
gli chiesero due pistole è un'automobile
perché avevano un regolamento di conti
tornarono dopo una settimana ma erano
visibilmente insoddisfatti e allora
alfonso prontamente gli se il nome del
destinatario delle pallottole lui lo
seppe e il giorno dopo a quell'uomo
furono recapitate effettivamente due
pallottole
l'ho uccisa alfonso non lo fece per la
licenza di un mandato oppure per la
promessa la speranza di avere una
ricompensa
ma semplicemente perché voleva
dimostrare che lui poteva farlo che lui
poteva fare tutto
e difatti o curto dalla sicilia lo
chiama lo affidò di fu egli stesso
padrino e poi gli affidò il mandamento
di tutta la sicilia centrale
mi disse alfonso che tale era diventato
il loro rapporto di confidenza che gli
raccontò del suo primo omicidio commesso
negli anni 50 con il suo padrino in una
piccola città vicino palermo
poche anime era settembre ed era la
festa del crocifisso
mi sovviene subito una domanda ma questa
vicenda è mai stata raccolta in un
verbale
lui mi disse no
e allora lì capii che la scintilla di
quell'uomo di quell'alfonso aveva appena
illuminato una notizia di reato che per
un decennio era rimasta sopita e allora
sull'aereo di ritorno per palermo mi si
affollava nella testa
ogni frase che lui mi diceva che mi
aveva detto la festa del crocifisso fine
settembre
due uomini non ucciso e così chiamare il
maresciallo il maresciallo del posto
gli dissi trova tutto ciò che necessiti
per sapere di questo omicidio
mi non ebbe buone notizie per me così lo
rintuzza e gli dissi bene cerca tra
tutti coloro che abitavano quel paese in
quel periodo il giorno dopo sulla mia
scrivania arrivo un appunto con scritto
francesco giusto assassinato il 15
settembre 1957 il fluire temi pensieri
era questo se c'è un uomo che è stato
assassinato
ci sarà sicuramente un fascicolo da un
fascicolo del 1957 non può che essere la
corte d'assise delle madonie
e quel fascicolo il giorno dopo era
sulla mia scrivania impolverato sì ma
aveva da raccontarmi ben due cose la
prima era che l'omicidio era stato
commesso da due persone a volto scoperto
e questo lo sapevamo ma la seconda era
che una persona aveva assistito una
persona che a quel momento aveva 11 anni
un bambino e che candidamente aveva
ammesso di essere presente alla scena
e allora se quell'uomo esisteva andava
cercato perché semplicemente doveva
essere interrogato gli poteva essere
sottoposto fascicolo fotografico e ci
poteva essere un riscontro a quanto
alfonso aveva appena detto si poteva
inchiodare alla responsabilità
dell'omicidio più efferato d'italia il
suo primo omicidio
il primo di 100 ma sarebbe disonesto non
dirvi che la disillusione mi prese e mi
fece anche fare questa domanda a chi può
mai importare di un omicidio commesso
più di 60 anni fa però la scintilla
aveva già fatto il suo corso e aveva già
illuminato l'identità di quel testimone
antonio che aveva circa 66 anni e che
era emigrato in germania giusto appunto
50 anni prima
più che una scintilla fu un'esplosione
quel giorno ad amber un paese un piccolo
centro della regione bavarese era un
giorno di festa
tutti erano felici o meno ostentavano
una felicità
forse in fondo ero anch'io felice quel
giorno o meno credevo di esserlo del
resto mi trovavo lì con la mia famiglia
con i miei nipotini a dirigere un
piccolo passeggino però di quelli
costosi con tutti gli optional e quelli
che con i passeggini che ti fanno
credere questi addetti al marketing che
servono veramente
e si stava facendo sera quindi
cominciavano ad accendersi le luci le
luci dei lampioni dei focolari domestici
e all'improvviso sentito un boato
un boato che in un certo senso scosse
come una campana presente nei enel nella
parte antistante della mia mente la fece
di suonare e questa campana mi portò ad
un passato ancora più remoto come una
sorta di madeleine proustiana possiamo
dire è
in questo è passato remoto e mi trovava
nelle madonie quindi circa nel 1957
avevo circa 11 anni ed era la festa del
crocifisso mi ricordo questa cosa mi
ricordo questa cosa perché c'erano i
fuochi d'artificio c'erano le luci mi
trovo un po in disparte in una parte
poco illuminata e senti questo forte
boato io pensai subito che fosse un
fuoco d'artificio e puntando che guarda
in alto ma non vidi nulla quindi bossi
mio capo in alto ma non c'era alcun tipo
di bagliore poi lo sentivi nuovo
un'altra volta un altro boato però
questa volta era più vicino era un boato
freddo di una luce bianca che si trovava
proprio in prossimità quindi o guarda in
basso questa volta eviti un rivolo un
rivolo nero per terra lo proseguì
questori volo con lo sguardo quasi come
se risalisse una rapida di un fiume e
questori volo mi portò ad un iride un
iride pallida quindi di un uomo che era
morto in questa su questa pallida iride
su questo uomo steso per terra ha
battuto come una bestia c'erano due
figure informi come due abitanti
dell'incubo che erano curvi su
quest'uomo come delle fiere pronte a
ghermire la preda è poi così
all'improvviso si dileguarono nella
notte nel buio
queste in questa immagine si fece
presente nella mia mente dopo più tardi
quando ero in casa in car in casa e
nella mia casa li adam berg quindi la
sera stessa c'erano ancora gli ultimi
bagordi per strada e io mi trovavo lì
nel letto vicino a mia moglie e
girandomi verso i lei non potete far
altro che sorprendermi in un certo senso
dell'incontro in salita delle cose
dell'esistenza perché se io in quel
momento mi trovavo vicino a lei steso
nel letto in quella casa in germania era
per una foto una foto rubata
possiamo dire così e infatti adesso mi
era ancora presente lì nella mia mente
questo ricordo nitido era appunto
ritorna voli nella mia sicilia nelle
nelle madonie e ricordo che alla porta
bussano dei giornalisti che sarà la mia
madre a mia mamma signora una foto a una
foto di suo figlio sai per quel fatto
increscioso che è successo ieri
quell'omicidio sophie è l'unico che ha
visto qualcosa e mia madre così
candidamente disse certo come no una
bellissima foto è quella della comunione
ce l'ha pure vestito buono
io da quel giorno in poi fui un
testimone non fai più la persona che ero
prima non ero più quella persona che
magari aveva dei sogni avevo un sogno
nel cassetto come si suol dire o che
magari stava già pensando a raccogliere
quel mazzo di fiori che poi avrebbe dato
alla ragazza che si deve alla ragazza
che tanto mi piaceva che si trovava di
fronte alla casa di mio zio il fornaio
oppure non contava nemmeno più che anni
avessi qualche numero di calci e di
scarpe calzasse ormai era una persona
che aveva visto nel cuore di tenebra del
mondo e quindi era come se avessi un
certo senso rubato quella fiamma di
prometeo che però la gente non voleva
quel quella cosa che nella gente ignora
che esista ed è per questo motivo perché
da quel momento in poi fui un testimone
ecco in quanto tale in quanto persona a
questo punto di vista disprezzato ormai
da tutto il mio paese fu costretto ad
emigrare fuori del settore mirate
soprattutto poi alla fine per la mia
incolumità
andai prima a catania dove c'erano dei
miei parenti e poi anche da lì fu
costretto ad andare via ad andare in
germania dove adesso mi trovo
e a proposito di lincoln sequenzialità
delle cose dell'esistenza di come queste
capitano manco a farlo apposta il giorno
dopo busto l'interpol a casa mia
l'interpol che busto ancora una volta
senti questo forte boato
quasi come se rimbomba se appunto nella
mia mente e l'interpol e bussando e
aprendo la porta mi chiese signore
possiamo farle delle domande riguardo un
caso di tanti tanti anni fa ed è in quel
momento che un certo senso quel boato
quel esplosione che ho sempre avvertito
dentro di me che avevo sempre evitato
quasi come se fosse un abisso che
cercasse di raggiungere meno ho mai
guardato però nei confronti di questa
bis
forse dire finalmente diventata quindi
una scintilla più che un esplosione
questa volta fu una scintilla perché
finalmente quella luce che era sempre
stata presente nel passato come nel
presente
finalmente aveva rischiarato con le due
figure finalmente quelle due figure
avevano acquisito da una sembianza umana
finalmente quella luce come una fiumana
accecante
in basso queste persone me l'aveva fatto
e scorgere per quello che poi in fondo
erano erano semplicemente due uomini che
avevano trucidato una persona lì di
fronte a me cal aveva una battuta come
se fosse un animale qualsiasi finalmente
quindi il passato non aveva battuto alla
mia porta alla porta della mia mente
come se fosse una sorta di ramingo una
tempesta in una notte tempestosa che
cerca di entrare battendo sulla porta
della della mia taverna no finalmente
quel passato si presentava a me faccia a
faccia su un tato avanti ad un tavolo
seduti con una candela che ci illuminava
il volto ad entrambi e finalmente con
quel passato poteva fare i conti
finalmente io mi sentivo pronto partire
la sicilia finalmente dopo tanti anni di
ormai è finalmente ero disposto a
rispondere alle domande che il giudice
avrebbe rivolto quindi si può dire che
effettivamente non fu un'esplosione fu
una scintilla
eccomi qui per trarre delle conclusioni
della storia che abbiamo raccontato
siamo partiti dalla considerazione
fondamentale per cui le idee tra di loro
si accendono e producono scintille la
costatazione tuttavia non è la sola da
tenere in considerazione occorre bene
tenere in considerazione da un lato che
è possibile vedere stino spente come
sopite così com'è possibile allo stesso
tempo che quelle idee signorino tra di
loro
ebbene abbiamo abbiamo dato la
dimostrazione plastica di come
effettivamente il testimone dapprima
giovane inconsapevole assistere
all'omicidio e quindi rimbalza
immediatamente alla cronica giudiziaria
diviene noto in tutta la sicilia
in quel momento in lui c'è una idea che
un'idea di giustizia e allo stesso tempo
è un'idea di speranza la speranza di
poter restituire giustizia quella
vittima antonio sa tuttavia che se resta
lì quella scintilla per lui diventerà
dinamica e quindi costretto a fuggire in
germania dove soltanto dopo degli
accertamenti effettuati dal pubblico
ministero dopo anni rispetto alle
vicende accadute che tornerà in italia
ma questa volta torna per porre un masso
su quella vicenda e per in qualche modo
staccare quel cordone che l'aveva legato
nel tempo è una considerazione
fondamentale è che in sostanza le idee
possono restare subite e possono
restarlo anche per tanti anni
tuttavia lo stesso tempo è possibile che
tra di loro con le idee degli altri con
le energie degli altri si contagino e in
qualche modo si accendono e quindi
producono una speranza la speranza che
riguarda i protagonisti la nostra storia
e anche noi stessi grazie a tutti
buonasera
[Applauso]
[Musica]